il y a eu l'année de la femme il y a eu
l'année de l'enfant
1982 a été désigné en haut lieu pour
être l'année des cons c'est étonnant non
je me trouve ce soir chez le professeur
makoly luchard qui a été choisi au lieu
pour organiser pour superviser cette
année des cons alors tout d'abord
professeur Mercy de nous recevoir chez
vous
et alors j'imagine que si vous avez été
désigné pour assumer cette lourde
responsabilité cette mission importante
c'est que vous devez être vous-même très
con
il s'agirait rien disons simplement que
je suis un vrai con ou sacrément con si
vous préférez
la première question que tout le monde
se pose c'est en un mot où sont les cons
bien que votre question ne soit pas
particulièrement conne je vais tâcher
d'y répondre
voici la carte chronographique de la
France qui nous montre assez clairement
la répartition géographique des coûts
dans l'Hexagone en rouge vous voyez les
départements à forte densité de compte
en jaune les départements à moyenne
densité envers les départements à faible
densité chronographique si l'on compare
cette
à celle de la répartition démographique
que constatons nous nous constatons
qu'en France c'est dans les départements
les plus peuplés qu'on rencontre le plus
de bien qu'on peut dire qu'au niveau de
la spécificité absolument d'ailleurs le
con n'est pas immuable il migrate comme
nous le montre cette troisième carte
nous voyons ici la répartition
chronographique estivale de la France
l'été en effet les cons rejoignent du
littoral par ordre de très serré il
s'agglutit ainsi pour ne pas perdre ne
fût-ce qu'un mois par an la chaleureuse
promiscuité de la ville il forme un
conglomérat continu de Calais
et de Port-Vendres
à Nice
audit alors qu'ils sont un peu con sur
les bords
alors seconde question que se pose tous
les gens qui nous regardent professeur
macaulayuchard c'est à quoi reconnaît-on
les cons à sa façon de s'habiller avant
fin disons que c'est le meilleur moyen
pour ne pas se tromper et comment alors
comment s'y prend ton précisément c'est
très simple mettez 10 personnes dans une
pièce observez les biens sur ces 10
personnes il y en a au moins une qui est
habillée comme les neutre c'est un con
est-ce qu'on peut enfin est-ce qu'un con
peut-être déconnifié c'est pour ainsi
dire impossible même s'il est prêt à
temps à l'heure actuelle si court est
décelé à tout disons qu'une fois sur 100
il peut être traité de quoi de con de
conduire effectivement à vous entendre
professeur on a l'impression que cette
année des cons s'annonce très bien il ne
faut pas mettre la charrue avant les
bulles comme on dit chez nous mais en
effet je touche du bois ça me semble pas
mal parti quels sont les grands
événements qui vont marquer cette année
des cours les événements habituels de ce
côté-là nous n'avons pas changé
grand-chose par rapport aux autres
années où tout c'est toujours très bien
passé pour nous nous le reconnaissons
non c'est plutôt sur le plan culturel
que nous avons fait un très gros effort
puisque nous allons inaugurer le musée
des cons un musée immense qui montrera
toutes les œuvres réalisées par les cons
depuis 20 ans
c'est énorme oui on s'aperçoit que c'est
considérable bien plus qu'on ne pouvait
le penser et quel sera le prix d'entrée
lors de ces salles 500 francs pour les
cons 10 pour les autres je ne vous cache
pas que nous espérons faire une belle
recette qui me sera d'ailleurs
intégralement remise pour être sûr
qu'elles ne sont pas intelligemment
dépensées ou placés ceux qui seraient
trop con après tous les efforts que nous
se font déployer pour organiser cette
année alors je crois qu'on peut dire
quand même professeur que tout a été
prévu jusque dans le moindre détail pour
que cette année des cons 1982 soit une
réussite absolument totale sur tous les
plans je vous remercie le professeur
macoli Huchard quant à moi il me reste
plus
ah vous êtes trop con alors vraiment
c'est l'année
[Musique]
c'est